so after this guy's done eating he gets
up and he has a blind walking
[Laughter]
i was stink eyeing him the whole time
too
just mortified like yo i just [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about that could you
imagine this guy could hear me just
saying all this [ __ ]
oh my god how [ __ ] hilarious dude
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast how is everybody doing we have
ed park back in the house
what's up guys uh previous episode we
actually did a review
of one of our favorite korean films
chingu which means friends
friend and uh y'all liked it i'm so glad
too right and i just had this
conversation about
you know asian cinema and we mentioned
on the podcast before how people talk
about
there isn't really great asian films
like
yeah be quiet
so be quiet no it means a lot to me too
because um
i don't know why i'm still on facebook
oh really
it's where i like write movie reviews
after i see something
and um honestly like you said it's
because you have this space and you
created a space or
it's like now you can just be like well
talk about these great korean or not
just korean asian films out there or you
might [ __ ] on it too
yeah yeah yeah speaking of [ __ ] on
oh man
your how was your uh holiday from
christmas
to uh new year's that was nothing i
didn't do [ __ ] like
right it was literally nothing this is
the first i don't i think this is the
first christmas i haven't spent with my
parents
yeah ever since i was born damn yeah
like even even when i came here i always
flew back to um
sacramento and the interesting thing is
a lot of people don't understand i
actually still have the same friends
since i had in high school
right like till this day so what we did
instead so we usually have a
uh thanks a thanksgiving friendsgiving
right
every year in sacramento if i don't make
that i usually make the friendsgiving in
christmas
done ever since we were like 14 and we
still do it now
right and so this is the first year we
had to do it all through zoom
you did something special and then you
watched wonder woman
and then well let me let me just preface
this all right so we're going to talk
about wonder woman and the reason why
i won 84 w84 the part two right
the reason why i watched this was
because mariel is a huge
gal gadot fan right loves gal gadot
whenever gal gadot appears on a screen
she just screams
she loves gaga though that much so she
watched the new fast and furious series
or that chunky
she loved it so like gal gadot is like
her female hero yeah right watching this
film
and i she could already tell like i'm
like seething because i'm so pissed at
how bad this film is like i only watched
the first 30 minutes
30 minutes of it at first right and so
she looks at me all pissed
and she goes if you don't want to watch
it then leave whatever
right she's like mad at me because i
don't like this film it's a bad film so
i go upstairs and i leave
and i'm like i can't believe she likes
this movie so after the movie's done i
come back
down and she goes this is the worst
this is the worst movie i've ever seen
she starts griping about how nothing
makes sense yeah and she's not critical
of films at all
that just goes to show how bad this film
was yeah well like
as it goes on like everybody spent their
christmas
probably alone like you and i did and
you
put on wonder woman 84 make maybe get
some christmas cheer but
what the [ __ ] like just kind of like
ruined the end of my night
i know let me just preface this too so
for a lot of people who watch
marvel cinema right or whether what
comic book cinema
you know superhero cinema or whatever
for people who never grew up with it
sometimes it's hard for them
to watch these films because there's a
lot of stuff that's not
said in the movie that's kind of
expected you to know as an as the
audience
you just suspend your disbelief you just
accept okay this is happening okay this
is happening
but then if you don't know anything
you're just like
why is this happening exactly so it's
already kind of far-fetched for people
who don't
understand the superhero world this
movie took
that and then did 10 times worse than
that yeah so if we could just talk about
number one this was a film that cost
what 200 million dollars
where did that money go i'm so confused
well apparently they consider it success
because
uh weekend was like 80 million off of
theaters and then the hbo subscribers
jumped like crazy
so the sad part is they so they signed
on for
a wonder woman part three now because of
the success of this one
quote unquote success god dude the
beginning of the film is so funny to me
because
right off the jump it was me mariel and
her best friend we were watching it
and i we started laughing and then we
couldn't figure out why we didn't like
this mall scene where she's doing these
acrobatics beating up these bad guys and
and you know becky her best friend looks
at me and she goes
what's so bad about this i was like you
know what it is
it looks like this is a marvel or a dc
verizon wireless commercial
like she's jumping through this beating
everybody up and she stops she goes this
is the lowest rates ever
with 5g i thought it was a [ __ ]
commercial
yeah it was super bright over saturated
and you look it up and she's like
apparently they chose the 80s
because it was all about consumerism and
i don't know i don't know why they chose
a's i assume it's because the director
was a child during the 80s
because this is a children's film you
realize right yeah off the bat like
you kind of start to you accept that
it's a children's film
but like there are good children's
movies like children's
movies don't have to be bad exactly uh
it says
it seems like for the sake of targeting
children you can get away with
plot holes or dumb like
binary behavior right like the first one
was
actually actually really deep
and for me it was like because uh wonder
woman representing
um like just the purity of the gods like
amongst humans right
yeah and seeing still seeing the [ __ ]
best
in them even through the war and all the
shooting and fighting
she still believes in humanity because
they must fight aries
because it's because of aries that men
hate each other
right but what does she find out it's a
lie and aries argue
see these humans are a piece of [ __ ] you
know men
are inherently terrible they fight on
their own i only inspired them
yeah they chose to hurt each other right
but wonder woman still proves him wrong
because of her relationship with steve
trevor
he's an above average guy but yeah i
mean he's a dope
guy he's not dumb he's actually really
smart and he'd be indiana jones in any
other movie
but compared to wonder woman he ain't
[ __ ] right and that's the point of
it and and she proves everything's wrong
by choosing to love you know and not
killing that girl with the face
oh yeah yeah all like all these things
and she chooses love
you know and sees the best in humanity
after the war
right and she thinks yeah yeah so she
thinks bruce
did you cut to this and it's just like
everyone sucks
everyone [ __ ] sucks every man on
earth
is terrible you know but it's a kids
movie
it's a kid's movie you know what the
part that really just
made me just pissed at it mind you i've
only paid attention to the first 30
minutes the other stuff i i saw later on
because at the first 30 minutes i just
walked upstairs i can't do this
it was so
trevor comes back to life right
she doesn't question it at all right
just
oh my i know this is you because i could
feel it's you oh yeah
i'm just walking holding hands like
nothing's wrong i'm like wait
yo you're not gonna question this look
what happens they
they [ __ ] yeah it's some other guy that
possesses his body
yo if if if this is a wish-making stone
and it can make anything happen
just [ __ ] make him come to life why
did he possess some other man
she just had unconsensual sex with
non-consensual sex with this dude yeah
she raped this dude this guy had a job a
light
family everything is to pay they take
over his apartment and [ __ ] all day
yeah like it's completely okay
that part i was my jaw dropped
because i was like hold on a second how
did he get into that body
right completely just blew this over and
this is what i'm talking about where a
lot of like comic book stuff they go
over these details
that they expect the audience to know
this was this is extreme you know
right how did they get the body well
[ __ ] this guy in his life right he
he's a perfectly normal dude probably a
perfectly fine human being he just
loses his life and then wonder woman's
just like let's
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
and yeah at the end she doesn't even
tell him she's like we i saw your dick
yeah
he smiles at him it's the worst thing
ever i'm like this is
terrible even beyond that right the
the the main idea wait the main
basically how the story just goes
mcguffin right
right yeah how the [ __ ] does he know
about it
how does anybody know about this exactly
where does it come from all these things
you want to know that's the
you you the chase it kind of has this
indiana jones going around the world
figuring out what this thing is but it's
uh it's just a stone it's just it's
really old
oh [ __ ] it says it comes from a really
really bad god that was it
where come a really really bad god
as oh my god it was just the dumbest
thing they didn't put
any backstory to anything so this is a
lot of problems that you see this is a
problem that i see with a lot of like
korean dramas you know right but you
know korean dramas there's this
there's a lot of leeway to it right
because you just want to feel a sappy
lovey-dovey feeling so you just let it
go yeah
this with a film if you don't give any
backstory or
a reason for us to like characters hate
characters it doesn't
matter and i really this is the the
straw that broke the camel's hump
is when the main the villain
he he has a wife and he has a son yeah
and this kid is full-blown full chinese
[Laughter]
and even if we knew what the mom looked
like this kid's full asian
not only that yo does this kid eat
sleep drink water he's just hanging out
at his dad's office 21st century yeah
not only that like even just jumping
ahead where he
gets lost and the dad comes back looking
for him he [ __ ] comes running out the
woods
here i am like where were you you know i
out of all that [ __ ] that you just did
with like making wishes for everyone
like how convenient that you like found
your son so easily that would have been
your next biggest problem
what he was missing when i saw that
asian kitty is like my son
i'm like what was that just like the
diversity card
just like you could put this one asian
kid i said that out loud i was like oh
is he
he has an asian son and then everyone
was looking at me like
something was like i thought i don't
know casting choices
at least the main characters we thought
like these are great actors
and that's a diversity card thing you
know yeah
because it doesn't make sense unless
there's a story
that his wife they adopted this asian
kid or something
but it was they just wanted us to accept
that this spanish man
has a full-blooded asian kid it was he
asian or are we
wrong did we just go back to the film
he's a blue ock
maybe we just weren't paying attention
like closely oh that kid was
full-blooded
i was shocked i thought that kid was
gonna start speaking vietnamese for a
second i was like yo what the [ __ ]
i mean like uh going back like cheetah's
character
uh kristen wiig she's like
adorable quirky in her own way and she
wishes to be like diana
and she gets powers and whatever
but uh and then she gets popular but
like what does she lose
out of that like you used to be so nice
yeah exactly what's most important to
you so
that was the other thing that was so
stupid right i don't think they've ever
set up that her
niceness was the most important thing
about her if anything that was something
that she hated about herself yeah
so why would that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense why did
even if she wanted to become the most a
fiercest apex predator she turned into a
cat or
a cheetah i don't know
that that was it it wasn't like i want
to be specifically a cat
somebody out there some god chose that
she should be a cheetah i guess
you know how [ __ ] lazy this film was
and this is
after the 30 minutes i gave up and i
went to go back to watch the rest
because
you know ray was telling me how terrible
it was i was like okay now i have to
watch this
it was the scene where they wanted to
incorporate the invisible jet
it just goes i've never done this before
but
invisible that was an invisible jet i'm
like that's it
this is this is what it takes and then
they totally ripped the
thor ragnarok scene where they're flying
in the spaceship and there's fireworks
oh yeah yeah
straight up from thor they just ripped
it
and then don't even get me started about
how useless that armor was
oh my gosh what was the hype what was
that about
it did nothing it didn't nothing so i
don't understand
what the point of that was um toys but
why would you want to buy that toy now
it's going to break
[Laughter]
buy this toy it won't do jack [ __ ] for
you yeah that [ __ ] was so funny to me
i'm like yo this is a prank this is a
prank
even the storytelling devices like um
kristen wigs by herself in the park and
she gets accosted by
drunk dude and wonder woman comes and
saves her
right and he goes flying and it's like
comedic
and heroic and it's cool right but when
she does it she does the same thing
she gets her [ __ ] justice like she
should because she touched them again
you know and instead it's turned like
now she's bad
she's bad for doing the exact same thing
wondering
if you had the power of wondering like
you wish you would and you wanted your
own revenge
that might speak to the next movie we
talk about later
it was just it's like they didn't care
about
development at all and on top of that
like here's the thing too
like i'm not very like i watch a lot of
film but i'm not very hyper critical
about a film that i watch one time
yeah i just watch it to just enjoy it
you know it's like it's like with music
like i don't like it when people try to
dice up and chop up music too much when
you just heard it
one time through this podcast is brought
to you by shipstation if you sell stuff
online you know how busy 2020 was
everyone and their dog was shipping
online well get ready for 2021 it's
going to be even bigger and better
that's why online sellers like you
need ship station no matter how much you
sell
shipstation makes it super easy to
manage and ship all your orders from
all your sales channels faster cheaper
and more
efficiently listen no matter what you're
selling amazon etsy your own website it
doesn't matter shipstation brings all
your orders into a very simple
interface whenever i've actually used or
actually sold
merge i actually use shipstation it's
super easy i just want things to make my
life easier and especially when it comes
to labeling and shipping things if
if you could have a process that makes
that part easy especially because it
tends to be really tedious
shipstation is going to be the one for
you it's the one i've used it's dope
you'll love it so to get 2021 off to a
great start
just visit shipstation.com use my offer
code geniusbrain to get a
60 day free trial that's two months free
of
no hassle stress free shipping just go
to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page
and type in geniusbrain that's
shipstation.com enter offer code
geniusbrain shipstation make ship
happen it's the same attitude that i
have with film i try to watch it the way
like the director or the actors want us
to
feel what they have and then second time
i'll be like okay let me see what i want
to pick apart about this film
this one was just it it was just so
blatantly bad
you know what i mean it's like what was
the moral of the story i don't know
but that's the thing it was be careful
what you wish for
but how does that apply to any of us as
children now
to our kids or any generation be careful
what you wish for
yeah like why how like we don't have
[ __ ] like if you wish for anything it
doesn't show up
yeah so this is a how does this fantasy
of wishing for something and getting it
teach anybody a lesson because in the
beginning at the mall there's a girl
who's super inspired
by wonder woman right you watch the
movie and
and cheetah wants to be like wonder
woman and the whole idea is you should
look up to wonder woman but the moral of
the story is also
you shouldn't be like wonder woman or
else you'll stop being nice
yeah i don't get it it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
yeah like nothing nothing lined up
no nothing it was like i was watching
like if you if visually it just seemed
like it looked like a quilted patch like
just patches of random stuff just
stitched together
and i couldn't follow what the film was
trying to tell me like even the lesson
about the moral of what we're talking
about and the beginning
like greek god olympic games with the
shitty vhs titles that didn't
work together total clash anyway but
what was the lesson of that you know uh
those olympic games like don't cheat
uh aren't they warriors are there rules
in war like don't they kill
yeah you know like don't cheat to like a
pragmatic problem solving to get towards
your goal in war
i don't know it seems commendable to me
it was
it wasn't even so clear-cut either about
the non-cheating part because for me
when i saw that i didn't understand
where she cheated
yeah you know so when i saw her
it wasn't her mom who was it was the
warrior yeah her aunt yeah she stops her
right and saying like cheating is bad
you have to win the warriors way or
whatever that it is right
but they didn't even direct it to the
point where i understood where she
cheated
not only that where does that lesson
come full circle to the [ __ ] plot of
this movie
think it would tie all the way to the
you know it's supposed to somehow but i
don't see the connection
like it doesn't make any sense it's such
a stretch same director too
which was shocking for me yeah okay so
uh
the first movie i looked this up because
i was just like why
yeah why why why and the first movie was
produced by rat pack
and that's uh zack snyder's production
company
so it's his camera his lenses his gear
probably the productions
that hired the people to make it look
the way it does yeah somebody else
completely wrote it too
um then i guess after batman v
superman or something after that there
was a change at warner brothers
this guy named jeff johns became the
kevin feige of the dc
cinematic universe okay and since then
they've been aiming towards kids
more often so that's why you got
something like aquaman is super campy
shazam is like a kid's movie too and
uh justice league got a crazy campy
rewrite
and just turned into crap terrible which
show goes to show
now like you're gonna see it's like
apparently two more hours of an entire
film like
yeah in on hbo max because they this guy
just
whacks everything zack snyder did in the
past wow
so with this one it was now this new
kind of production direction they're
going for children
but what the [ __ ] was this i could even
see a like a five-year-old looking at
this film and saying what the [ __ ]
yeah you know it's it's that bad it's
colorful i guess
like i don't know it's nothing to learn
it's it's hard to say what i could even
like about it the jokes
uh when were stale like i remember just
even this small joke right he goes i can
get you the best 19-inch tv
and then all i heard in the back was
that's all i heard like that's a very
very soft pitch that like if you
are faithfully watching the entire dc
cinematic universe and you know like of
being geeky like me
and it doesn't do anything to serve any
expansion to where
it's going to the next ones and it's
just this
isolated movie if you're an isolated
movie you should be as good as logan
100. logan
it's top i think it is my favorite
uh superhero film of all time yeah i'd
say probably top three
amongst them if i had to pick and choose
somewhere there and then when they put
it in black and white i was like how is
it even better
like this is amazing that was a film
that if
whether you're a dc cop or a marvel fan
or not or a superhero fan or whatever
you could enjoy that film no matter what
it is right and because there's a lot of
stuff too that you you know if you don't
know anything about comic books you'll
probably
leave uh it'll make you wonder why these
things are happening specifically the
relationship with professor x and
wolverine
but at the same time they did such a
great job in like character development
in that film you kind of just accepted
and move on
yeah you know like this man has
telekinesis and this guy has
claws and heels but you're just getting
along with the story
you know when you're watching this
you're like okay this guy
wishes to be the stone yeah
that oh my god i can't believe i skipped
that over when he said
what he said that part what i want to be
you
[Laughter]
i want to be the stone oh my god
i'm trying to figure out too if i if i
had this stone and i wish for something
what is something that's so important to
me
that that thing would take away and i
don't know what that is
so you're gonna lose two inches in
height you'll be five foot eleven
instead of six one yeah
[ __ ] i don't know like what do i hold so
dearly too that i couldn't trade for a
billion dollars
yeah and things would turn out so bad
that i'd be like okay
take it back yeah the entire earth
the whole world took back their [ __ ]
wish all collectively
like as if mr satan was calling upon the
earth to erase her like i'm like
okay like wonder woman somehow convinced
him with that
shitty ass monologue yeah at the end
you're right oh
let me tell you something i know a lot
of hood people that had a billion
dollars they'd be like
[ __ ] y'all i'm good here's why it's
important from here to transition to our
next movie
because of the theme of the truth in
wonder woman
84 they're trying to say that the truth
will set you free
the truth is what's most important
and old boy is totally antithetical to
that
yeah right i mean are we going yeah
towards that
well let's talk about this right so
since we're going to talk about amazing
um cinema specifically when it comes to
asian cinema
like i watched a lot of korean film i i
only saw a few
i mean i've seen a lot of like wonkawaii
films and stuff like that but obviously
as a korean american i'm going to
connect more to a lot of these korean
films
everybody knows i would say everybody
but i'm pretty sure a lot of people know
about old boy
right one of my favorite actors of all
time
asian or not chemical yeah so
[ __ ] good yeah um what a film that i
actually like
more than old boy is actually ah which
is i saw the devil
right except for this that film has one
little part i didn't like but we'll get
into it we'll
we'll maybe review that let's review
that one too yeah old boy is such a
trippy film
like i mean we'll go for scene for scene
but one of the things that i
i guess like now that i watched it again
i'm not
because i watch this super young right
and i think the the shock factor of how
what what the film turned out to be like
the end of the film
is the thing that i remember the most
that i didn't really appreciate all the
other stuff that was going on
like specifically when you guys watch
old boy if you love anime
you'll love old boy yeah like the way
that it's
framed directed and shot it's like an
anime yeah but with people and it's
actually done well well because how many
reiterations or how many um
films have you seen where they try to do
bleach or not or something
you know and it's a terrible film it
never turns out as good as the anime or
the comic book or whatever
but old boy the way that a shot is shot
like an anime yeah it's so good
yeah it's i think yeah i first saw it i
guess
college or just come out and the whole
idea
behind it was just like oh it's [ __ ]
up it's [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up and
watching it now it's just
oh man it is deep into the human psyche
to the core um i guess what we were
going to also talk about was the
american old boy
and that seems to be what it missed it
was just about how [ __ ] up could it be
how much more can it be [ __ ] up than
the korean one there's just no
there there is so there was an american
old boy that was shot
just it's so bad like i i still have yet
to finish that film
because it's that bad i was literally
watching it before i came here and i
turned it off because
not that i was out of time i was just
this is just not worth talking about
yeah it's that same trope that people
keep [ __ ] forgetting it's like
you have to give you have to give a
person a reason to care yeah you know
and that
film doesn't allow you to care so
there's no payoff for all the crazy [ __ ]
that's happening
and also too sometimes when you adapt
these asian films specifically like for
me anyways i can only speak from
experiences like korean films have a lot
of like cultural nuance that doesn't
translate well to american films exactly
right exactly so one of the things that
you'll see in the film oldboy that's
really dope and it's like stuff that you
see
in even represented uh represented in
our film uh [ __ ]
is that it's a very serious film but
there's a lot of funny [ __ ] yeah
it's so funny that's that's a trope that
you'll see in a lot of
[ __ ] up korean films yeah no matter
what like
another film for example that reminds me
of that is the whaling the wailing
gems of funny ass moments like it's
scary as hell it's it's a thriller right
but the main character is a [ __ ]
korean homer simpson
yeah it's it's it's like a tree house of
horror for koreans
it's a simpsons episode but oh my gosh
we'll get to that one
too it's genius um but yeah i wrote
notes again
um i'll go through the plots but if you
want to catch up with all the little
nuances and [ __ ] we'll get through that
we appreciate that you guys like that
last one and this one we actually really
like doing this too
so here we go uh
old boy uh let's see it came out 2003
uh directed by pak chan up
one of the one of the best directors of
all time
right and his other movies out of his so
this is the
second movie of his vengeance trilogy
first one being sympathy for mr
vengeance
old boys the second one and lady
vengeance
all great films he also made one of the
best vampire movies of all time
thirst i actually never saw this bro i
never saw it
one of the greatest vampire movies i've
ever seen okay
and we'll get to that too okay so yeah
uh just look up his imdb
and um park chan wuk and you'll see just
he makes masterpieces
all right so in 1988
a businessman named odesu is arrested
for drunkenness
missing his daughter's fourth birthday
and so it opens up and he's a
[ __ ] he's a police station right and
he's trunk
and it's basically showing us how he's a
piece of [ __ ] right
like he's drunk he's causing a stir
he's making fights he's trying to pee in
the corner he's hitting on some girl
and he's like has his shirt off and he's
flying all over the ground and [ __ ]
it's not acceptable in korean culture
right obviously but it's not all
uncommon
it's it's drunk in the worst way
possible too and this is where you get
to see it
this this film is a [ __ ] up film but
this is that glimpse that i'm talking
about when it comes to green cinema
about making funny [ __ ]
happen in serious films and this is how
it starts off it's actually [ __ ]
hilarious yeah
like how drunk he is which the american
one totally missed
it's not funny at all it's just look how
shitty this lives
it's like right off the jump in that
america they missed they missed the
market yeah like this is already missed
like it's like on a funny side note if
you guys go to k-town and you're out
late at night well not now because of
pandemic yeah
you'll see these adishi's yeah
everywhere
dude
they always do this [ __ ] too when
somebody try to calm them down and
they'll grab
but funny story too me this podcast is
brought to you by raycon my friends if
you are listening to earbuds with wires
you might as well just go
back in a time machine and stay there
your stupid face
you need to get raycon now i know a lot
of you out there thinking that in order
for you to have high quality
audio in your ears without wires you
need to pay
bucco money well you haven't heard of
raycon because they make it affordable
and they also make it sound just as
amazing
raycon makes great sound accessible to
everyone their wireless earbuds start at
half the price of other premium audio
brands and guess what if you think
having white stems dangling out your
ears look ridiculous because i do
that's something you don't have to worry
about with raycons baby stop looking
stupid get some raycons my friends
listen i love my raycons anytime i'm
biking
anytime i'm walking around i got my
reikon earbuds in my ears so raycon is
now
offering 15 off all their products for
my listeners and here's what you got to
do to get it
go to buy recon dot com slash brain
that's it you'll get 15
off your entire recon order so feel free
to grab a pair
and a spare that's 15 off at buy
raycon.com
brain that's by raycon dot com slash
brain
so uh when i first met bart and joe
years ago right this is when we didn't
really know each other
we went to this one korean barbecue spot
that was uh 9.99 for all you can eat
it was this best spot i think originally
it was 8.99 so we were
we were broke as [ __ ] so we used to go
up there all the time um
in classic old drunken korean man
fashion the most terrible thing ever and
this is actually a moment that me bart
and joe share where we actually solidify
our friendship even more
because we realize how [ __ ] up we are
as human beings
because so it was me bart joe and geo
and then we're having our korean bbq
uh dinner we're eating and we hear
somebody screaming in the back
it this older korean man right he's
going off
screaming at the top of his lungs
you know don't look at me whatever going
off right and he looks at this this
couple
sitting at a at a small table having
korean bbq he walks over to them just
drunk fat as [ __ ] you know tight collar
shirt belly sticking out
he goes like you guys are japanese
people right
like saying like you [ __ ] japanese
[ __ ] this
dude looks at him she goes i'm korean
[Laughter]
i'm telling you that korean speaking
korean to him
like i'm korean i'm korean and he's
still screaming at him
that he's japanese going off just drunk
as [ __ ]
looking like odesu in old boy we've all
seen this
every korean has seen this man odesu and
he is
presented as an everyday man right what
does his name mean like
getting by one day at a time um
so it's established that he's a piece of
[ __ ] you know
um and his friend joo hwan the pc bang
owner
picks him up well obviously the 80s
there's no pc bang at the time
picks him up at the police station and
desu
is kidnapped and wakes up in a sealed
hotel room
where food is delivered through a
trapdoor and so the next thing we see is
the trap door opens and they're feeding
him and he starts begging them
right please please why why wait why am
i here why am i here
right and at the same time he gets
[ __ ] crazy angry
and starts cursing them out right this
is uh
very hand like to be two emotions
at the same time and it's pretty
hilarious
but um it's it's one of the many
themes that obviously off the bat you
because as an audience you're watching
this
yeah well why is he in there he's just
in there all of a sudden he's asking the
same thing
and then he asked if i knew how long
i was going to be in there would it have
been any better
yeah and one of the themes of this
uh film being the truth right and
a lot of unanswered rhetorical questions
um
because it has so much to do with his
isolation
here and him in his own mind and
his inner dialogue too which you when
you say like an anime or a manga yeah
it's
so much inner dialogue which the
american film completely cuts out for
some reason like you don't get into his
head
and as you read this uh monologue it's
really really getting into his character
and his
just i guess his where the seeds of
vengeance
which you really really need which is
what the american film missed
because it kind of goes into you're
trying to figure out now too
because of his because he lived in
solitude and you don't really get a
glimpse of really who he is besides he's
a piece of [ __ ]
but now you're trying to figure out is
this guy [ __ ] crazy yeah like is he a
crazy person and that's what these inner
monologues did
that allowed to set up his character
development like you don't know
if he's a sane person or not you don't
know if he's was he really trapped in a
room
it just kind of leaves you there's this
jarring feeling that you have
just yeah he's he's on the brink of his
like edge of his sanity
right and in that room too he goes like
like ed was talking about it goes to
this point where he's
begging gets super angry that's what if
i knew this time that i had here
wouldn't have made it any better then he
goes into a a stage of vengeance
he has this little dummy carved out on
the wall and he starts practicing
punches to a brick wall
because he's like when i get out of here
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill the person who
put who left me in this room
and what does he also do though he
starts writing in his journal
talks about every [ __ ] up thing he
ever did he actually starts thinking
about it
not only that he's going through names
in his head which is wild he just starts
listing names names names names names
names names to me who could have done
this to me which is important if you're
a korean dude and you're
resentful with that you remember names
and faces and like what the [ __ ] did i
do
yeah you know um so
he's watching tv deju learns that his
wife has been murdered and he is the
prime suspect
he passes the time shadow boxing
planning revenge and attempting to dig a
tunnel to escape
and uh this is pretty important to all
of us um
uh where his character
through the movie becomes an
encyclopedia he knows these little
weird knowledge like trivia things
because he learns so much watching tv
all the time and people like you and i
we were raised by tv
yeah and um and so
it the tv also shows up in a cinematic
way how time passes through world events
and also um well if you're korean and
you're watching it
um do really big national events like
even a mall collapsing or presidential
elections then they show 911 and whatnot
and then it gets to which i really
appreciate it too because just didn't
just time jump out of nowhere and then
we have to figure out
as an audience where he's at they
already kind of
allowed us to put our mind at peace by
showing those events right so it doesn't
become a
huge part of the story but now they're
getting callous he's
putting a tattoo for as time goes by and
you see his determination he's
as he gets actually getting into shape
um other parts it's showing like um he
has that picture in there and what you
were just saying about
this movie being [ __ ] up but funny
that
picture that drawing of that really ugly
face
it says laugh and the world laughs with
you weep
and you weep alone and he's laughing
right
but he's laughing alone so it goes
and he had cut his wrist he tries to
kill himself
right but they take care of him right
and they won't even allow him to die
they won't let him die
yeah and even when he's like trying to
jack off
to the the the the pop star
and he can't go off try to kill himself
again
dog hey i i told you
i i told you about how i was just in a
[ __ ] trailer home alone for four
years bro
you get to a point where you're bored of
porn you're just like
why am i doing this and then you just
kind of you try the no nut thing
just to challenge yourself hey let me
tell you something when i was in that
quarantine for 10 days
i jacked off for two days straight and
that's all i had in me
i had no reason to jack off anymore i
was like what am i watching this stuff
is filthy
i started i started judging myself i was
like you watch this
sick [ __ ] what's wrong with you and i
just sat there i'm like
there was only a couple things i could
do cause i couldn't eat food because i
couldn't taste anything
and all i had was pouring and jacking
off yeah and i already
don't watch porn that much anyways and
i'm like you know what it's been a while
let me dust this off real quick
let's see what's
and i was like yo this is nice two days
i'm like i'm disgusting i can't do this
anymore
i hate myself oh man but
you weren't totally alone and you didn't
kill yourself yeah and
and so the next part
let's see he gets tired of jacking off
15 years have passed
um since he was in prison it is now 2003
um with the story because it started in
1988 it's not a new century
uh just before digging himself to
freedom daesu is sedated and hypnotized
um he wakes up on a rooftop and sees a
man on the ledge ready to jump to his
death
the man asked him even though i am no
better than a beast don't i have the
right to live
so that was actually the very beginning
of the movie right oh that's right
he's holding on to his tie and he's like
who are you
what are you what are you doing or
whatever and now we're seeing
that up to this point a man was on the
roof
with him trying to commit suicide and
desu just happened to wake up and stop
him from killing himself and so what
actually
what we're caught up to now is that desu
was telling this man
his story to this point about him being
locked up and everything
and then the man starts to tell his
story
and desert gets up and walks away
and as he goes down the elevator steals
that lady's sunglasses
[ __ ] the man kills himself jumps off the
legend kills himself
with the dog in his hand and he laughs
he [ __ ] laughs i if that says
anything about where he is
at that time in his character at a
mental state it's like
like uh what's you know what's hilarious
like i just got called out
for that that um i can be overwhelming
and i talk a lot
and then i have a problem listening and
then you're like ed let's
let's review old point i was watching
that scene like
oh man people are really offended by
that
they're offended by that scene or well
the fact that like
you know if you this is desu's character
he's he's still selfish well he's been
alone
and he tells his whole story and doesn't
even listen to this guys he just gets
cohen
that's crazy that's that that just goes
to show like how
[ __ ] up i am because when i saw that
scene i cried
laughing laugh
i think you're supposed to yeah it's
supposed to be a funny one
it's like joe look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know this guy he pours his
heart out tells him about
his 15 years in solitary confinement and
this guy's about to jump up and just
goes
all right
[Laughter]
it's just a weird funny moment oh my
gosh
so desu leaves the man
and tests his fighting skills on a group
of thugs he just goes into an alleyway
and just starts
fighting some thugs learns some new cuss
words as his first cigarette
buzzes so hard he passes yeah um
afterward a mysterious beggar gives him
money and a cell phone
desu enters a sushi restaurant where he
meets mido
a young chef so
what's the order what's on the menu oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah the most disgusting
thing ever
yeah a lot of that's a fad now
apparently
no way man i can't take this so ed has a
odd fear of seafood and i can only
imagine
you watching this scene of a live
octopus how it made you feel
i can't even watch finding dory oh my
god that was character this one has a
very odd fear see when he comes from
seattle
it's called thalassophobia i haven't
actually learned it
man i don't know it could be it might
even be this one i don't know
it could be like fishing with my dad and
just hating it
and um yeah experiencing different kind
of octopuses out there in the sea with
him
one of the funniest things that ever
happened when we used to live together
we were watching tv
and there was this uh we were watching i
forgot what it was but it was open brain
surgery
disgusting just blood everywhere you see
this like pulsating brain
and i'm disgusted by this because it's
weird to see a human body open right
he's watching it like it's nothing this
was like eating snacks and [ __ ] watching
this [ __ ]
all of a sudden we flipped the channel
like discovery channel as an octopus he
goes
start screaming i was like bro
and that's why i found out he had a fear
of a seafood and i
can't do i'm sweating right now
so that means you definitely can't watch
uh my octopus thread on netflix no
oh my god dan keeps like dude octopus
are intelligent i'm like great
don't like leave it on the watch list
sorry
but anyway so he eats a live octopus
because
he wants to eat something alive uh
say something about his character or i
don't know needing to feel alive or
something something
um it's in there though
uh then his phone goes off and it's a
taunting phone call
from his captor and after the phone call
or during the phone call i guess uh mido
touches his hand
to ask about i don't know what the [ __ ]
it was something about the temperature
of his hands or some [ __ ]
and he passes out and
because he passes out vito takes him to
her apartment
and in a frenzy desu tries to force
himself
on mido in the bathroom of her apartment
however
she is armed with a knife and
successfully fends him off
desu attempts to flee the apartment but
a sympathetic
and intrigued meteo confronts him mido
explains to diesel
uh tezu that she is romantically
interested
in him but that they hardly know each
other and she is not ready to
be intimate they reconcile and begin to
form a bond
interesting yeah
so he tries to rape her and she says
it's okay
she likes him and she still wants to
help him out
which kind of goes to show how [ __ ] up
she is you're right she starts
sympathizing
with him about being alone right
and losing her mind too and being on the
edge
uh which is uh
well what we can do pretty much if if
you're confused about this right now
they're hypnotized they were hypnotized
daisy was hypnotized coming out of jail
or the prison
and apparently she was hypnotized as
well they were hypnotized to fall in
love with each other
if that doesn't this doesn't make any
sense to you let's compare it to the
american scene
right in the american one the girl is
reading his notes
and he freaks out and chokes her and
says he
is about to kill her now that's really
different to americans
in a way it seems like because maybe we
can accept the fact that
uh violence domestic violence is more
acceptable in american film
but maybe it's too tough for people to
swallow the fact that this guy tried to
rape someone and this girl still stays
with him
yeah and you're missing out on the point
of this movie
about revenge uh there are no rules
revenge when you go into revenge and all
these things
um it strips people's humanity down to
its core
where it tears apart their heart and
they have nothing
they have nothing right yeah why would
these two nothings
then stay together yeah these rules
don't apply yeah
so like that's what chris rock says uh
two crackheads can stay together for
life
you can't go to church it won't be a
crackhead right yeah
so uh interesting way i mean if that's
how i'm picking it up most people find
it
really [ __ ] up but the story goes on
um
after he recovers deju makes an attempt
to find his daughter
discovering that she was adopted he
gives up trying to contact her
and at this point i think when he finds
out where she is
um he's crying but he turns away from me
because she
he doesn't want me to see him crying
right but he turns around and starts
laughing yeah this duality things keeps
happening it's a theme
um a split personality under stress
uh this is a little thing i learned
through my therapy sessions i don't want
to say what it is because we're not
professionals here but this is actual
legit
psychological disorder um incredible
filmmaking to show that happening people
might miss it but he's going through
psychological stress
um let's see
when i when i saw the film again and i
was watching him
kind of going through those like weird
psychotic moments of
when he becomes vulnerable and when he
becomes sad or something happens to
where he's an emotional record where he
starts laughing
you know it just reminded me of that
that one saying it's like when the whole
world
you know that's that's what it seemed
like he was referencing to me that
when you laugh the world will laugh with
you when you
you cry you'll cry alone exactly so when
he feels uncomfortable or
vulnerable he goes to just just laughing
right whenever the situation is so
[ __ ] up he goes to laughing
right that will get that will come
through
later um let's see
he finds the chinese restaurant uh that
he made
that he ate every day in prison um by
following a delivery man
now i gotta ask you if you ate one thing
for 15 years you're pretty sure you
could
find it out of like 200 spots in l.a
yeah yeah 100
have you ever like experienced actually
something like that where you can follow
your tongue
to i mean it's origins or more like
breaking down ingredients i mean maybe
not so much like breakdown ingredients
but there are certain things that i've
eaten for so long in my life
that um let's say my mom had takeout or
whatever she didn't tell me where it was
but the moment i eat it i'm like i know
what restaurant this is oh
you know like this is a place in
sacramento called
is the korean chinese champion place
right yeah
if i have something from like
specifically their tongue sweep
their their fried sweet and sour pork
the chinese korean version of it
i know specifically it's from that's how
much i ate that [ __ ]
you know but there's this restaurant in
tacoma called tasty tai 2
right and i ate there every sunday after
church
right every sunday every [ __ ] sunday
and then
um they changed i had new owners you
could tell new servers all that and the
food was different too
yeah and after that i lived in seattle
uh
for work professionally and i have
literally eaten at every thai restaurant
and had tried
every pad thai all over seattle and i
was just looking for my new favorite
restaurant
and i found it when dan moved to this
place in northgate it's called thai
fusion
and we we dan ate there twice a day
every day because we love their pad thai
really
yeah and we got [ __ ] fat we ate there
every day for
months and then one day as i came in um
one of the servers was like
are you from tacoma i said wait what
you're are you uh edward park from
tacoma
oh my god it's like the chef remembers
you from tasty tai too used to eat there
all the time
i found the same chapter and you're like
dude this place is so
[ __ ] good i just like the pad thai
and i just happen to have found the chef
again
dude how [ __ ] fat were you yeah
where the chef knows your first yeah and
last name you
fat [ __ ] where i'm from and where you're
from
that's hilarious dude
i would have been very much flattered
and embarrassed at the same time a
little like
okay well i felt a little special but
but yeah it's like i'm gonna throw in
some extra meat for you
oh yeah
[Laughter]
oh my gosh man oh man moving on
let's go back to more [ __ ] up stories
so he finds a private prison
where people pay to have others
incarcerated
deju tortures the warden mr park who
reveals that daesu was imprisoned for
talking
quote unquote talking too much he is
then attacked by guards and his stab
that would manage to defeat them this is
literally the wikipedia i just copy
pasted by the way but basically uh
he gets in there and he
first off there's a guy sitting on a
chair that he sneaks up behind
then what happens like holds up the
hammer and that's
actually that infamous photo you know we
can talk about that
some other time but he's holding up the
hammer but then
he kind of does a quentin tarantino
thing and he draws that line
yeah and uh yeah it's it's weird how
there's just
this director makes this incredibly
visceral
violent [ __ ] so entertaining yeah
you watch it and you're like well i
enjoy this
it's so [ __ ] up it's weird because
it did a very interesting job of first
it painted this picture of him
being this trash ass human being but
then he gets put into solitary
confinement for 15 years
and now you sympathize with him it's
almost like you want him to get his
veggies
you want it to happen and this peak this
this for me
in the film it's where you it really
solidifies how you
you start to feel about him now right
because at first i'm like oh this guy's
a trash bag
you know he probably did something
[ __ ] up and that's why he's in the
solitary confinement
but then you start empathizing with him
he's like well could i have survived in
a place for 15 [ __ ] years and not
knowing why i'm here
and then you sympathize you empathize
with him and then you want him to get
his vengeance
but this moment too what it also showed
me was oh he lost all of his humanity
yeah his his humanity is gone now yeah
like it's not there because
you're gonna see in that scene what he
does to this guy is how he tortures him
yeah and this is like he's not a human
anymore
you know all that matters to him is um
yeah getting his revenge right or like
really trying to find out who did this
to him
and as
yeah uh then it gets into the infamous
hallway fight
or i mean well he pulls out mr park's
teeth
his tongue is like all over the hammer i
mean like very visceral filmmaking
um and they had they had that hallway
infamous hallway fight scene
so he rips out his teeth with the end of
the hammer that you rip
nails out of the wall he places it in
between his tooth
and prys off his [ __ ] tooth from the
root
that way i watching that scene over
again
still makes my toes i like how did it
they made it look that [ __ ] look really
real
i think in korea at the time it was just
the real 2000s
the other thing i picked up from this um
a lot of these type of korean movies
these thriller
types is well
first you gotta see the hallway this
hallway scene and then the one in the
american old boy
they have the same weapons like two by
fours pipes bats and knives
but they're in america why don't if
anyone had just a gun
like someone should just [ __ ] shoot
somebody you know most gangsters and
prisons they have [ __ ] guns
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but the the
that's why this movie couldn't be
translated because korea's limited to
the fact that guns are illegal
yeah you know which helps storytelling
honestly to get around
such an easy bang you know that's the
hard part about like films with guns
there's a reason why
it's unrealistic when you see these gun
fights because
the the end result of somebody firing a
gun is usually that person dies in the
first couple of seconds
that's why when you see these gun films
there's always
things ricocheting off of things nobody
gets hit somebody pulls a gun he somehow
runs away
five meters and dodges 36 bullets yeah
you count the number of
gunshots shot in a movie and the number
of times somebody gets hit it's
incredibly improbable yeah then they'll
spray like an automatic rifle
yeah and then nobody dies so when people
have a beef with a two by four
breaking over someone's back like uh
it's like come on man you you eat up
films or someone gets shot in the
stomach and finishes all the way
hey i've seen somebody get a bottle
smashed over their head and they were
fine okay
i i i'm not saying that it's super
believable that that would happen
yeah but i'm saying like it's more
believable than shooting
like [ __ ] scarface
he gets shot a hundred times and he's
still standing up you know
cocaine's a hell of a drug yeah
cocaine's working for me
you know so yeah it was um very visceral
with the
he gets a knife stuck in his back and
he's still fighting it's really long
take
uh this is the most iconic fight scene
in probably all
of like korean cinema or cinema in
general yeah
it's just one long sideways dolly shot
and in complete action i would argue
that there's one movie that
kind of got up there on par is uh ajishi
or man from nowhere
the final knife fight scene yes yes yes
yes yeah
ah she is such a good movie
yeah so good oh and we have so much to
talk about yeah
but this scene is so cool because you're
going to see number one the choreography
was really dope
i'm not sure if there was choreography
or they just let them do whatever the
[ __ ] you wanted
but it's just this sideways dolly shot
that a lot of people actually i've seen
try to imitate this
and it's actually not easy very
very hard yeah right just a sideways
complete choreographed or
non-choreographed fighting scene of just
back and forth
mayhem you know and something about uh
christopher nolan
and zack snyder try to do it with batman
um with a longer like six versus one
kind of fight
kind of wide shot i mean they you can
see where it's coming from like uh
today's american action movies and
superhero movies
taking from hong kong like action films
too
and and like uh asian like cinematic
technique
and the cool thing about this too is
like you get to see the ability
of chebinshik as an actor right so
the reason why you have certain films
like in action filmed anyways and
this is my opinion once again and um
they do a lot of these camera whipping
camera whips
fast cuts is because it's based on the
ability of the person who's fighting
yeah right you have to when they throw a
punch whip the camera yeah
turn spin the camera around with a jerky
camera shake it up a bit cut on the head
to hide that person's uh ability to
fight on camera
inability yeah inability to fight on
camera yeah
so when you have this it's actually
pretty amazing to see
how great all these actors are
specifically chemistry who's not a
martial artist at all
at best he's probably pushing 45
something 50 by the time he filmed this
first time he's like in his 40s early
yeah man and he lost a [ __ ] ton of
weight like he looks like a completely
different person from the
how the movie starts yeah he was his old
fat [ __ ] yeah and they got committed
and he got really skinny
like to start like this whole journey
for him
all right so he finds out
deju's captor is revealed to be a
wealthy man named
lee wujin wujin gives him an ultimatum
if daesu can uncover the motive for his
imprisonment within five days
woojin will kill himself otherwise
woojin will kill
mido so what happens is uh dezu is
coming out of that
prison you know uh he he has a tapes
with him
and he's all bloodied up though and he
collapses
and a mystery man puts him in a cab
right
but he hears i think he says something
back i forget the line
but he says something that he recognizes
and he knows that that's his captor
this guy puts himself in the game now
he reveals himself but we thought that
this movie was a journey
to uh for his revenge to find out who
this guy is all of a sudden this guy's
helping him
find his revenge he wants him to reach
him
right and the game changes where
it's no longer about his revenge but
finding the truth
right so uh
daisy's captor we got through that um
we also see when he's confronted like
this who puts that hammer to his head
right
and woojin has the device a little
ticker time bomb for his heart
he put a pacemaker in his heart right to
stop yeah blow up his heart or whatever
um and it's going to show that this guy
doesn't care if he lives or dies
yeah he's playing a game he's [ __ ]
with him so hard
yeah and it also shows that when
originally this film like we said before
was about vengeance
it actually turns out it's about the
truth my vengeance doesn't matter as
much
unless i find out the truth because how
insane is it that he was locked away
for 15 [ __ ] years without knowing why
yeah and now
like we said before his motive has
changed it's like i need to find out why
right before and if this guy dies i
can't find out
this is the midpoint of the film he has
woojin in his hands he has a [ __ ] hat
he could get his face but then for what
what's the point
very important part of the movie where
now
like yeah that when we're we're talking
about
vengeance and the man's journey and all
that like what
the movie changes philosophically closer
towards is what the truth means
and what it means to all of us because
because imagine how unsatisfying his
revenge would be
for him to just do this to the person
who captured him but he doesn't even
know
why he has to live with that for the
rest of his life
he lost 15 years of his life his wife
was murdered doesn't know where his kid
is at
and he doesn't even know why how
unsatisfying is that murder that he just
committed
so uh that's who goes with the game
he plays the game with and to find out
uh
where this is all going and what happens
is because uh mido was chatting with
uh wujin but she didn't know it was him
and so tesu couldn't trust her so he
tied her up
and in his absence of mine left her
there tied up
and she gets now uh handled by mr park's
king
the prisoners right and they want
revenge for the [ __ ] he pulled at the
prison
but what happens again a suitcase full
of money
millions or billions of one
right and he says all right and they
leave
this is going to be a theme as it keeps
going like when there's
these interventions um
tezu and mido get close and have sex
very uh intimate scene let's say
we'll get to that later meanwhile
chu han which is uh tezu's friend the pc
bang owner
tries to contact desu with important
information but is
murdered by ujin he's talking about
woojin's sister on the phone with tezu
and this guy is hiding around the corner
listening in
have you ever talked [ __ ] and somebody
was listening in yeah
you know what's so [ __ ] funny and
actually bart and joe
i remember because i i talked about this
this it was your moment and they
actually took this moment they put into
a sketch i was like oh [ __ ] that's
actually ed's story
but they used it into a sketch and i was
like they should have asked you but
um this fool told me the funniest
[ __ ] story ever
it's you're eating at a restaurant
there's this guy
that just uh he has sunglasses on
a table and he has like this waitress
just doing
stuff for him putting sauce in his [ __ ]
or whatever and this was looking at this
guy like look at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] like this guy's bossing
this lady around telling her to [ __ ]
put sauces in his food
so after this guy's done eating he gets
up and he has a blind walking
i was stink eyeing him the whole time
too
[Laughter]
just mortified like yo i just [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about that could you
imagine this guy
could hear me just saying all this [ __ ]
oh my god how [ __ ] hilarious dude
i [ __ ] died laughing i'm like i can't
believe these
this [ __ ] was talking [ __ ] about
a blind dude well imagine though
if the blind man got up and his cane was
a [ __ ] knife and he stabbed me
woojin listening in takes the cd and
breaks it in half
and stabs uh chuhan
to death yeah for talking [ __ ] and he
warns
tessy over the phone yeah like don't
talk [ __ ]
something about talking [ __ ] is a
trigger
or woojin isn't it yeah
and uh i think chairman the director pak
chanuk
has a lot to say about what talking [ __ ]
means
especially when you watch this movie and
correlating with korean culture and the
han we talk [ __ ] so well
yeah it's part of a language it's so
good i built my whole career off of it
oh yeah
yeah but what this movie the vengeance
trilogy
i saw the devil whatever is putting
into action the words we say the
terrible things we say
because when someone says i think my mom
has said she would rip my lips off and
shut up right and you see these movies
and these acts like i will rip
your lips like in um i saw the devil
that fat dude is like laughing at him
and he's like
go ahead keep laughing i'll rip your
mouth open and he does it
oh that part is so like korean so if you
guys don't understand
like the way and once again this is from
a korean american perspective
and it's probably how it is in korea i'm
only assuming right just because i know
i got like this one angry message from
this hyper korean dude
it's like what do you know about korea
huh you never live
there oh you said did you have a stroke
i read that one i was reading this like
what's your point bro
you don't know anything about korea yeah
i was like
yeah i'm talking about my
korean-american perspective suck my dick
dude
but like korean people if there's any
asian language that's so good at cursing
it's the korean language because it's
very descriptive
there's something that my mom said to me
once and i'm just remembering it now
she said to me because like she i was
wrong right i was being punished and i
remember i looked at her with like this
dirty look
and what she said if i translate it is
she goes look at me like that again
i'll rip out your eyes chew that [ __ ]
and swallow it
[Music]
like it's like who says that today even
the way you just said it was so rhythmic
and syllabic
it's poetry like that poetry yeah
you [ __ ] dingleberry dog [ __ ] that's
not my mom
so these movies are an expression of
people acting out the visceral language
like of the korean language that's how i
see it
so moving on let's see
um he does his homework and he ends up
at a school and he finds out let's see
te su eventually recalls that he and
ujin
had gone to the same high school and he
had witnessed
in committing incest with his own sister
he told jooheon what he had seen which
led to his classmates learning about it
rumors spread and woojin's sister killed
herself
yeah leading yeah he was taking to seek
revenge
he was eating her sister out or some
[ __ ] like that or was he yeah it was
it was some [ __ ] visceral [ __ ] i was
like yeah i remember watching that scene
as a young person i was like what the
[ __ ]
is going on like it keeps going there
yeah
this movie keeps going there and in my
mind i'm rising the line
i would have told everybody too i would
have told
you as a young person i probably
wouldn't be able to keep my mouth shut
it's like yo
i thought i was still [ __ ] eating out
her sister yeah she's [ __ ] nuts
but to the character
of tezu though is that he's such a [ __ ]
talker he's forgotten about it
completely
he just does this all the time doesn't
mean anything to him he's just forgotten
about it
right and in present day
woojin cuts off mr park's hand causing
mr park and his gang to join forces
mr park is the owner of the prison right
um
daesu leaves mido with mr park and
leaves
base woojin so uh this is where
um he and vito have a conversation
and she's against him going to confront
fujin
but he knows now that that it's not
about revenge
it's about he needs to know why why he
was locked up
and now he thinks he knows yeah
i know like he's going to confront him
because i talk [ __ ] about you you're not
your sister yeah and he's gonna go and
tell him that and he's probably
who knows what he's gonna do from there
yeah he's like well now kill yourself i
found out
yeah exactly so at woojin's penthouse
woojin reveals that mido is actually
desu's daughter
bhujin had orchestrated everything by
using hypnosis to guide daesu to the
restaurant
we mentioned that earlier raising them
to meet and fall in love
when they touched hands and so that deju
will experience
the same pain of incest he had did
so this harkens back to the mirrors
theme
throughout this film there's a lot of
mirrors and
mirroring shots saying
you know look you think i'm a monster
whatever just look at yourself yeah
you went in there because of you you
know and
you think like you could just forget
about it
i want you to feel the same pain yeah
right
he reveals that mr park is working for
him
and threatens to tell the truth to me
though
desu apologizes for his involvement in
the death of wujin's sister and
humiliates himself
by imitating a dog and begging
when wujin is unimpressed deju cuts out
his own tongue as a sign of penance
ujjin finally accepts jesus apology and
tells mr park to hide the truth from
mido
so you start seeing as the story goes on
um woojin is extremely wealthy
right extremely extremely wealthy and
this wasn't like an off the bat thing it
starts getting developed in the middle
of the movie
and i don't know if you've noticed in
every korean movie the bad guy is a
really rich person
yeah isn't it it has to do with power
yeah power and
and um because they're korea doesn't
have a race problem
they're homogenous company they have a
class you have a class issue
last issue um which goes to talk about
parasite
parasite is an entire movie about class
um and which is also why i want to say
like you can't remake parasite the way
they remain old boy oh a hundred percent
anybody tries to remake parasite i'm
gonna shoot their [ __ ] leg off
and i believe it's because um
in america if you want to talk about
classism you have to talk about race
yeah it's intertwined and the problem
with old boy
is that tesu is supposed to be an
everyday man
a guy who gets by one day at a time you
know
and the other guy you know juxtaposed is
super rich
he wins this game with money yeah he
[ __ ] puts a
bomb in his heart some money to do that
he gives the mr park millions in cash
to allow texas to live he makes a deal
with mr park to cut off his
hand for a brand new prison which
it's it's it's a whole lot of
you can call it criticism or just the
look like capitalism wins
money wins all yeah that the only reason
woojin really won is because he just has
the money and power to do so yeah
right that scene that you guys will if
you guys have seen this him or if you
are going to watch it
watching odessu
bark like a dog was uh hard for me to
watch yeah
it was like he already lost his humanity
in one way right in terms of him just
empathizing
with another human being in terms of
like killing somebody and death
yeah and now it's gone to the point
where he's groveling like a [ __ ]
animal and he doesn't care
because the audience at this point is
expecting another big fight scene aren't
they yeah like he's going to [ __ ] up
ujin or something
right uh-uh like this guy has it on his
head
like and it's there's also this huge
reflection of like
how the the pain that he
felt in terms of like woojin's eyes
right right it's like
you were you were stuck in this prison
for 15 years
he's been stuck in his prison this is
the moment he ruined his life when his
sister killed himself
it's like he wanted him to feel
everything that he felt
right and he just wouldn't believe it
until he saw it for himself yeah when he
started barking like a dog
and he cut off his tongue we're talking
all that [ __ ] yeah
and then he finally feels like you now
feel the pain that i feel
it he had to break him down to his like
molecular
molecular level yeah and then strip away
his humanity to the point to be like see
that's how i feel yeah and
i've i've been there
before where i would i talked about
those uh three pastors and just how much
how angry it makes me right
yeah and when when i brought this up to
one of their wives
i said what if i did this to your kid
what your your husband did to me you
know
so one night just go you know you wanna
like she wanted to
talk with me this was like last year and
i actually
said that i was like what would you do
if i did this to your son
you know yeah and it's like that the
weird thing is my mom used to
babysit this harmony when she was a kid
and so i was like you know my dad too
my mom babysat you you're grown up you
have kids
what if i did this to your kids and i i
was explaining in a way and what i'm
saying
is that language of what if i did this
what if
your body or whatever or you know all
this visceral language
actually [ __ ] doing it yeah and the
pain
it really causes and so as it goes
woojin goes against his
i mean he played this game you know
saying
that he even said vengeance is good for
you right because
i believe vengeance is what drove woojin
to become so successful and have so much
money too yeah
and to be able to enact this revenge
like bit by bit by bit right
but he doesn't like to hit his own
advice when he told desu like what if
you don't
you know like if you kill me now you
know you'll never know or whatever
well woojin got his revenge
it's over now but now what nothing
boom he kills himself shoots himself in
the head because it's over right
and you know we've talked about this on
a previous podcast where it's so funny
how it's full circle where i was talking
about
my motivation to do better was to always
prove people wrong
yes and one of the the that was one of
my
it's it's a huge factor to my whatever
small success that i have in my career
now but when you reach this point of
success
through hate vengeance and revenge
and sometimes it's like these imaginary
characters right like
i i had this i used to have this
attitude of like oh i bet you don't
think i could do this [ __ ]
watch what i'll do right and then i
achieve it and that's what i'm done i'm
like
okay what next and then those people
you're trying to prove wrong they come
up to you and you're like dude i'm so
proud of you dude you're awesome you're
like
what like you're you're literally like
created this enemy yeah you created this
antagonist in your story and yeah
you're left with absolutely [ __ ]
nothing yeah
so one of the hardest things that i had
to do after we created um
uh we did goop the film was i was left
with nothing
because i did that because people acting
agencies wouldn't sign me because they
said i was just a youtuber
yeah so they're like oh you don't think
i can act oh cool i'll make my own film
you know well let's see how well i could
do right and they came knocking on my
door
they were like hey all these top
agencies you know whatever third tier or
whatever but they're pretty top up there
right they're like hey
we want to sign you um casting agencies
i had a bunch of meetings
i never even asked myself do you want to
be an actor
you know i was like wait
uh i don't think i want to be an actor
you know i did it for the sole purpose
to show
people that i could do something that
they told me i couldn't do
and i was left lost and i try to be an
actor for all year and i'm still act now
but
my motivation was off yeah so it didn't
it didn't leave me very happy at all
and so i was left with absolutely
nothing not nothing in the sense that
the film did well whatever right but
once you kind of check that box and you
and you've kind of created this
imaginary enemy and now that enemy is
gone what's your motive for continuing
this
this specific art which is acting when
your motivation was just to prove
somebody wrong that doesn't exist
anymore
you know so but with
that theme um now what we were trying to
say
the truth he had to find out the truth
and there's a there's a storytelling
device that
every movie has like i was mentioning
with wonder woman the lie being that
ares
or she believes in this world of humans
are inherently
are good they're just possessed to be
bad a lot of
protagonists believe in a world view
that's a lie and they learn
something and what i feel like
to learn is through this is that the
truth
will not set you free in fact
the truth was so horrible that deju cut
his own tongue out
right this movie is so bleak
it is it is depressing it's a tragedy
deju
loses all the way i have this film idea
that i want to do that
that's very reminiscent of old boy and
it has that is the exact
theme of the film is because that that
that phrase of truth will set you free
has always like kind of been a little
unsettling for me
because it's very relative yes right
like
truth is it can be weaponized or it can
be very healing
right there there's no set definition
for it there are people who have lived
their whole lives as alive but when they
find the truth it'll derail their whole
life so why would you even tell them
another film that did a really great
asian american film that was the
aquafina film yeah
was her where the main character
had a grandma who's dying of cancer and
her aquafinas
is like the truth will set you free but
the whole family disagrees with that
it's like why why do you think her
knowing that she is going to die
is going to set her free why do you
think it's right right
when she lives in complete bliss
thinking that she's completely fine
so this idea of truth always being the
answer for everything
it's very relative yeah and uh these are
the things i
i struggle with with my life in my
existential crises
uh crisis is i don't know but um
it's definitely when you uh
like have a crisis of faith when my
whole world was based around
uh this way of living this way of life
this
religion or this and that and then all
of a sudden it's a lie
the reason why i live and the purposes
that i had
and all those youth group hype nights of
the reason i live
when that changes um yeah
it's very very i can dare i say
dangerous
you know and very hurtful to the brain
and i believe what the truth the movie's
saying is that the truth will not set
you free
accepting the truth right yeah
but still as movie goes on
some time later desu finds the hypnotist
to erase the
his knowledge of mido being his daughter
so that they can stay
happy together to persuade her
he repeats the question he heard from
the man on the rooftop
and the hypnotist agrees afterwards
well that lying on the rooftop was even
though i'm no better than a beast don't
i deserve to live
afterward mido finds dazu lying in the
snow
but there uh but there are no signs of
the hypnotist
leaving it ambiguous if they should
really matter
mido confesses her love for him and did
two embrace
deju breaks into a wide smile which is
then slowly replaced
by a look of pain paid black
so i was talking about this with ed i
actually didn't pick up on this until i
saw it uh the film yesterday
was when i first saw the film and so
just to paint where this is like
the the hypnotist erases his memory
right
is what we're what he's alluding to
wakes up into this
snowy forest in the middle of nowhere
and his
daughter comes in and finds him she's
still madly
in love with him she doesn't know the
truth yeah she doesn't know what's going
on she just knows that this is the love
of her life and she's found it
they embrace they hug and i first saw
him kind of smile or whatever
and when i first thought for somebody i
just said i was like oh he lost his
memory now he could live his life
i watched that again and i'm like wait a
second that goes back to the thing of
like smile
you know when the whole world smiles you
when you laugh with them or whatever
yeah and i was like
wait it didn't work didn't work
it didn't [ __ ] work because the
question this movie shows
is that he wants to kill the beast
right but he doesn't want to die um
we're led to believe that he did wrong
by leaving that
man behind and he jumped off and killed
himself i believe daesu knows that
if he doesn't find his piece here and
doesn't isn't listened to he's gonna go
kill himself
yeah right and so he gets hypnotized and
he sees
his reflection in the window right the
theme of mirrors
yeah looking into the mirror and seeing
the beast in front of you
and the movie really questions
right there just this this last scene
itself
he wants to forget the fact that this is
his daughter yeah
he still wants to [ __ ] her how weird you
know what i'm saying
yeah but he wants to kill the beast and
they're together at the end is that a
happy ending
is what paktron hooks is asking us yes
ambiguous
like open-ended ending is he not a beast
like he's presenting it as a happy
ending for sure but this guy is still a
[ __ ] monster
is he not it kind of reminds it kind of
like made me feel like this
i guess like the overarching story too
i'm not sure people agree with this is
that you can't really escape your past
yeah you know it's always going to be a
part of you no matter how many times you
try
what you do has a ripple effect of your
future and you can't erase what's
already done
right so you know that's something that
he has to live with
right which i think that's something
that we all try to ignore
when we move on like we see this a lot
when a lot of kids go to college
they when they go to a university and
they're away from their hometown they
try to recreate this identity
right you see a lot of this theme
throughout everybody's life it's like i
want a fresh start but do you ever
really get a fresh start there are
things that happen in your past that
carry on with you as an adult
you think that the stuff the trauma that
you faced when you were a kid is not
going to affect you as an adult just
because time has passed it's still going
to affect you
and it's it's thematically something
that we always deal with as adults
and i see that a lot with um friends of
mine or even people that i meet
they think that they're so much better
than their parents they think that
they're so much better than all the
stuff that they happen
they don't want to go through therapy
and they're like i've already dealt with
it but we see it in their behavior and
their actions all the time yeah
how they develop their their [ __ ] up
relationship with their father
[ __ ] up with their relationship with
their boyfriend later on because they
don't have an identity of what a man is
in their household because their father
was gone
yeah you know and this is like a theme
that i see
constantly throughout life that i think
this film really hit well it's like how
do you
you can't escape what you've already
done in the past you could only try to
figure out ways to forget it but
can you really you know and um
even the idea of like uh speaking the
truth
too right uh where this movie goes to
argue
then yeah just shut up it seems to be
the biggest like overarching theme all
that [ __ ] talking or whatever
maybe don't say anything because the
crazy thing even in that case
it's not like he was lying yeah it's not
like he was saying
something that wasn't already [ __ ] up
him eating out his sister
is [ __ ] up it kind of makes you forget
the fact that what he's already doing
yeah [ __ ] his sister is a [ __ ] up
thing
to do right and then it goes to the
thing of like
and when i think about it now it's like
well what he said wasn't wrong
but there's a confusion with sometimes
with people where they think well what i
said was true what's the problem with it
it's not about what you say
it's about the effect that it has when
you said it and how you said it
consequences
and effect is constantly what's
happening in this movie
it's always something that the audience
doesn't know about
this great filmmaking is because someone
like tezu
just forgot because he's just a piece of
[ __ ] he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
and so even us as audience don't know
because he doesn't know
and and that's just the great journey
that this film kind of takes you on
even though until you choose at your own
discretion to go down this
[ __ ] up rabbit hole but yeah it
it it spoke to me really really recently
too
because uh people are asking me if i
feel better about
talking about some of these old church
stories that about my
hurt or my past or whatever yeah and i
was arguing
too that um it's not necessarily that
i'm saying the truth
that makes me feel better and then
speaking the truth isn't therapy like
and i i say i would argue that
saying the truth is therapeutic for
liars
people who are just constantly lying and
maybe they need to speak truth
for practice i see that yeah 100 like if
you've if you've lied to yourself your
whole life and you finally feel the
truth it feels like this weight is off
yeah but
if you're honest with yourself and all
these things haven't you and i
gotten in trouble just for keeping it
real yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah and so this movie is
enacting on
what if that joe schmo you completely
forgot about
become somebody who [ __ ] with you dude
tim always says is the best like tim's
like
you know what even when i feel people
that i meet who are
[ __ ] whack or you know somewhat like
fans sometimes who like disrespect me or
whatever or
i don't think that they're good at what
they do i'm always going to be nice to
them because watch them become somebody
and try to [ __ ] me up
[Laughter]
you know which is a which is probably
some good advice right on the other hand
a little opposite
i mean you know but you know it's true
though like you you do have a ripple
effect that you have that you don't even
know sometimes like uh yesterday i had a
conversation with uh
somebody i didn't know and this guy his
name is sam i don't remember his last
name but
i was on this app where you could you
know talk to people i forgot that i
downloaded yeah but he was talking to me
about how he used to
listen to me and he still listens to
this podcast now and he's like yo
like you keep me in check sometimes and
you know you kind of speak a lot of like
i'm like and i look at him and i you
know he's in politics now
you know you know going for his masters
and stuff and you know he's doing a lot
of stuff great stuff for like the asian
american community and i look at
somebody like that i'm like i influence
you you're better than me
i was like you're better you're more
articulate than i am you don't have to
do it in the guise of comedy
but you're so much better than what i do
but you have like my same fire but you
package it so much better right but you
don't
you don't know like the ripple effects
that you have with your words you know
i'm obviously very careless sometimes
with the things that i say
but i do have a purpose in what i'm
doing and sometimes i don't care
but i do understand that it can affect
somebody negative or positively just the
people that i affect negatively
i usually hate their guts so i'm like
take what you will right you know
right and i believe us being here um
this you know uh it's not about us us
talking the truth and now we feel better
now we're
two friends and we're listening to each
other yeah that's really good and we're
shooting the [ __ ] that's therapeutic for
me
and our truth is relative yeah and so
for daisu
if he had a friend like juhan the whole
time in prison he might be a little
better who knows
yeah you know i think it's there's a
whole lot of themes that goes really
deep down to the psyche
with someone who is in solitary
confinement and isolation
and the effects that happened that's why
when we watched this film the second
time
why that confinement part [ __ ] me up a
little bit was because the 10 days of
solitude
i only had 10 days and i lost my mind
and i was
out there in the middle [ __ ] nowhere
in a trailer home
for four years yeah so when i watch that
the weirdest part is how do i
relate to him that way yeah and [ __ ] i
even like look like him right now
but yeah this movie is a classic
it's legendary he deserves like an
honorary oscar for this
i believe it has the record for the
longest ovation
at khan's film festival really yeah
and then um it also won the palm door
it's
one of quentin tarantino's most favorite
films
yeah which makes sense yeah because you
know quentin tarantino films are very
anime yeah like very comic book strip
like maybe he should have remade it i
don't know
i feel like if he did remake old boy he
would do a
a decent job because his film has so
much
like underlying nuance to it and he also
has a lot of humor in these very serious
films right
kill bill so many funny [ __ ] moments
in that film so yeah american old boy
was
not funny at all it was too serious
it's toaster like that's that's the
beauty of korean film too
those that those crescendos of like
humor
and then sadness it makes the sad part
sadder it makes the funnier parts even
funny
that's what i like about it it also felt
like
um the josh brolin character was
enjoying
uh having to torture samuel jackson oh
yeah yeah during it but like this
is his characters seem more or less he
just has to do this
yeah and because he said he was going
there was no
enjoy that's what i'm saying it just it
more represented his loss of humanity
yeah because there was no emotion to it
when he's ripping out his teeth
he's not smiling ha ha i got you just
like hey i need this information
and you're going to tell me if i rip out
your [ __ ] teeth yes matter of fact as
a matter of fact
it's also in sympathy for mr vengeance
when
the first time he has to go to an
autopsy it's for his daughter and he's
bawling his eyes out and it's
so emotional the second time
he's he watches an autopsy of some
guy he wanted dead anyways and he's like
oh
right yeah like it's hilarious but also
showing character development but also
showing
like his loss for humanity
uh it it might be an american movie
trope but
it's it it might be too on the nose to
turn some
somebody into a maniac and all of a
sudden he's just a crazy man so that's
why
he's laughing when he's cutting samuel
jackson's skin he's skinning him
which is just not the flavor of the
korean version right you know what it is
it's
two it's two one note yeah it's two one
note and it's
two already explained it's like how
[ __ ] up can this be then
it's just to give it you know so at that
point there
there's no exploration in his character
for me when i was watching it it's just
like as a matter of fact they're just
going to keep on doing more [ __ ] up
[ __ ] yeah so there's no there's
there's no pull like i don't feel like
i'm
could he be what's the reasoning for his
character right yeah and we're trying to
figure they're giving us
little little easter eggs here and there
for us to kind of figure out as an
audience to navigate through his
his psyche as a human being and the
american one is like he's [ __ ] up
because he was locked up
yeah that's it oh he's crazy so he's
gonna beat up a football team of only
five players and they're in full uniform
playing cleats and there's only and
there's four girls watching them
and he beats them all up it was like
where's the rest of the football team
who would have [ __ ] him up yeah
there's just these weird things like um
does
spike lee play football yeah
he missed the mark really bad yeah and
that's why it's not even called a spike
lee joint
yeah apparently he just doesn't want to
call it that like i like i love spike
lee film
yeah yeah i mean his films are [ __ ]
dope i'm honestly influenced
[ __ ] you know that in justin's vision
well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
i hope you enjoyed that insight once
again you get a little piece of our
personal lives
you get a little bit of piece of this if
you haven't seen this film yet
watch it if you haven't seen it in a
while if you listen to this go watch it
again and it'll probably help you see
things a little differently
um this is i've probably seen this film
over like 20 times
yeah you know in here yeah i mean it's
been a while since i saw it again but
even every time i watch it there's
always something new it's like the bible
or something you know every time
you find something new i don't know what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah but you can find
ed at ed parkvp on instagram and
uh geniusbrings is every thursday and
sundays my friend we'll see you all next
time
thank you peace